you're entering the world of openness a
world of overused characters and cliches
and we were heavy acting is horrible and
terrible effects of the norm at the
world where plot devices are either over
explained or not explained enough behind
that door is a river of blood behind
that door - scary little girls behind
that Dora should be remake that fucks it
all up
you're about to enter the Stephen King
disables okay before you guys go nuts I
want to emphasize I don't hate Stephen
King he's a very talented writer has
written some very good stories but that
doesn't mean I had to like everything
he's done and on top of that that
doesn't mean that the movies a
miniseries based on this books are that
great either case in point the languor
Lee is
this is one of those drawn-out
miniseries from the mid 90s everybody
was hooked despite it's incredibly goofy
moments but we're then suddenly let down
by one of the silliest payoffs ever it's
long and silly it's over-the-top
it's a Stephen King miniseries let's
take a look so we see a bunch of people
arriving at an airport in LA one of them
is a little blind girl named ina what is
a woman named Laurel and one is a
British assassin hired to kill somebody
by who you may ask well by the director
himself Tom Holland today in London on
Saturday will have a pipe to celebrate
now you might be wondering why I know
who Tom Holland is well I did a little
research and found out that he directed
such movies as child's play and Fright
Night why does this matter it doesn't it
doesn't matter at all they were silly
movies then and they're silly movies now
why am i bringing it up then well I
guess I'm wondering why his name takes
up 2/3 out the credits I mean holy shit
his name is huge you've got all these
other people who cares Tom Holland
outlined it's shiny metallic clattering
it's bigger than Stephen King's name
well I guess if this is the same guy who
brought us this we're in good hands
by the way while watching this opening
tell me you don't want to hear this
music
the white zone is for immediate loading
and unloading passengers hopefully there
is no stopping in the red zone there's
also a pilot played by David Morris
who's travelling to Boston as a
passenger
so everybody boards the shamefully fake
CGI plane and wakes up to a shocking
surprise most of the people on the plane
have just vanished
would somebody speak to me please I'm
sorry but my aunt's gone and I'm blind
it's alright what's wrong
where is everybody they've gone they've
all gone what do you mean where's
everybody they're all right there wait a
minute you just want my tent rose and
you didn't notice any of them didn't
have people in it I know you're a pilot
but surely you know planes are more than
this where is everybody going on and
Viki and what the hell is going on here
with so much shut this brat up oh my god
is that Jesus please tell me he gives it
over-the-top performance I have a
meeting at Boston's Prudential Center at
9 o'clock this morning promptly at 9
o'clock that's what's important
thank you for this performance and the
actor you have chosen to give it truly
he will supply great laughter for this
review
so it turns out only a handful of people
are left on the plane all that's left of
the other passengers are material items
like watches and earphones even the
pilots have disappeared but does Balki
care about this of course not don't be
ridiculous now I have three questions
for you number one who authorized an
unscheduled stop number two where was
that stop made and number three why you
ever watched mr. Spock on Star Trek just
if you don't shut your cakehole you
bloody idiot I'll be happy to
demonstrate his Vulcan sleeper hold for
you did he just say Star Trek sound
badass so he puts him in a nose hole
don't believe me listen Oh knows how
long see and that seems to shut him up
for a while
meanwhile the pilot goes into the
cockpit to see if he can radio for help
air force control this is American pride
flight 29 do you read me over what but
it turns out nobody's responding on the
ground and the plan was too afraid to
land in one of the busiest airports in
the world so where are they gonna go now
we're heading to Bangor Maine the
Stephen King drinking game I don't care
I gotta take a drink of that Oh what is
your fetish for that place and of course
Balki doesn't like this at all
just Bangor International Airport
important business meeting in Boston
it's morning at 9 o'clock my wide-angle
lens is about to burst and I forbad Joe
would you please be quiet
you're scaring the little girl scaring
the little girl but he just get
castrated on that line scaring the
little girl scaring the little bear oh
hey hey speaking of which the little
girl suddenly sees what Balki is seeing
and discovers that most of his vision is
distorted by scary imagery
of course everybody wonders what the
hell that was about and the little girl
explains we all look like monsters doing
I'm sure we don't know what made you say
that I hear things sometimes people's
thoughts she called it shiny so yes it
turns out the little girl is psychic
might as well add her to the unexplained
psychic children's club a cease to exist
in TV and movies that's the craziest
thing I ever heard we also come across a
mystery writer who's trying to deduce
what is happening on this play and oddly
enough he's exactly like a character out
of a bad mystery novel I also had been
asleep what about you dear boy oh yeah
yes
I'm a mystery writer deduction is my
bread and butter
so I deduce that everyone was asleep
including all those people that were
subtracted along with the flight crew of
course dear boy
perhaps dear boy if I deduce a little
bit more my acting will become a little
bit more Chapa does anybody notice the
teddy bear out on the plane he looks
suspiciously like the teddy bear from
the shining the one that was giving a
blowjob for some reason another Stephen
King story coincidence or something more
I did you stipulate so they finally
reach Maine and for some reason nobody
wants to see what's actually down there
I really don't want to go down there I'm
just good stiff the song maybe this
wasn't such a good idea I'm scared
what's wrong with these people you're on
a plane where everybody disappeared how
the hell you gonna be safe there people
down there to question doesn't want to
solve our problem also don't you just
love how the adult is whining to the kid
and that kid has to make her feel better
what I really don't want to go down
there I mean I really don't if it'll
make you feel any better you're not the
only one
don't worry fully grown mature woman a
terrible little blonde girl will keep
you covered
looks like somebody's getting up smooth
landing over here your jobs in to its
full upright position please I don't
wanna die I just don't want to die and I
don't want to say they're lying anymore
so we're just gonna go with that take
but of course they land just fine and as
is typical of Maine
it's weird creepy and totally filled
with things that Stephen King is afraid
of this place smells wrong really badly
wrong okay we have to investigate we
don't have a choice why why do we have
to you know she's right we should go
back on the plane and wait to die oh
listen there's nothing to smell and
nothing to hear well this is getting
dull where's another wide-angle shot of
Balqis there we go you realize I can
turn you in for this mr. Toomy are you
aware of what has happened to us mr.
Toomy just oh Haiti an obnoxious
flashback and the crazy parrot that's to
Stephen King cliches are one I don't
want the hangover apparently Balki has a
flashback to when his father was angry
because he got an a-minus in class an
a-minus I got a trip to Chuck E Cheese
when that happened what happens to lazy
bums who lie down on the job Craig well
at least now we know where he gives us
handy acting Pro you understand that the
economic fate of nations may hinge on
this meeting though I don't have a time
frame what the hell do you know about
time I give him two more seconds before
he fully transforms into a cartoon
character we all know it's coming you
can't hold it back
so again they calm him down and they go
through the luggage conveyor belt why
don't they just go through a door they
go inside and find that the place is
abandoned plus little things like smells
and sounds have all been slightly muted
and it seems like the clocks have
stopped to spa well that's going on
Becky starts to hallucinate about his
father you had an appointment in Boston
I was kidnapped
there are no excuses and they play the
most common game in a Stephen King
miniseries who can overact with their
mouth over the widest will I am going to
explode father and I don't give a damn
you know what I dad not bad seven
centimeters Becky's dad's gonna have to
really overact in order to be that size
no it's not part of the big picture you
can drive the s-curve on your truck
through that hole congratulations
in this movie I think I call from the
dance of joy so he goes through an
airport security door which of course
isn't locked
Dinah's where she hears a creepy sound
in the distance so creepy that it forces
her to take off her glasses even though
it has no impact on her vision
dinah tell us what you hear it's very
faint a really terrible scary sound and
it's awful
a little like Rice Krispies after you
pour in the milk I'm sorry what was that
incredibly scary comparison again a
little like Rice Krispies after you pour
in the milk all right but a search out
for these guys but because they are part
of a complete breakfast but I know it's
closer than it was because something's
coming there's something making that
horrible cereal noise this movie really
just point the phrase horrible cereal
noise this is a phrase that needs to
exist it's coming don't you understand
it's coming and if we haven't gone by
the time he gets here or all going to
die we're all gonna die a snappy
crackling pop eaten so we see Balki
comes across another unlocked door where
he finds a gun in one of the storage
lockers well if there's anything this
movie is proving is that airport
security doesn't come down hard enough
you're out there aren't you but I'll be
gone by the time you get here I'm going
to Boston as you say there's none of
that stuff here but when we woke up it
was on the plane does nobody see him
right now maybe nobody is here when it
happened
no that's nonsense seriously nobody sees
him right now you're looking right at it
watch out I hear someone I feel a much
better looking idiots can see him right
in front of your fucking faces so Billy
from Power Rangers attacks and gets shot
but luckily bullets seem to have no
effect in this world so they get some
rope and tie up the doofus before he
acts any crazier I think it might be
wise to take a few precautions don't you
oh do you have to be so rough I mean if
we tried to do was kill somebody that
does it call for being rough this is all
very riveting but I think it's time for
another Shatner performanced I think I
found a fallacy in our thinking and it
is this we all assumed as we began to
grasp the dimensions of this event god I
swear his pauses were written into the
screenplay I swear to God I mean let's
count him let's count how many pauses
are in this few seconds I think I found
a fallacy in our thinking and it is this
we all assumed as we began to grasp the
dimensions of this event that something
had happened to the rest of the world
but the evidence doesn't bear that
assumption out what has happened has
happened to us nine pauses that's nine
pauses somebody just tell us idiot to
get to the point please mr. Jenkins can
we get to the point every now and then a
whole
in the stream of time not a time warp
but uh a time rip so he suggests that
might be a time RIP that the plane flew
into but that it doesn't work like how
most time travel movie say it works that
one can't appear in the Texas State
School Book Depository on November 22nd
1963 and hope to stop the Kennedy
assassination no that would be a friggin
awesome storyline this is the pass so if
you could actually follow any of that
they had to find some fuel and escape
fast or else they'll vanish with the
rest of time Dinah for whatever reason
decides she wants to find out more about
these language that Balki was talking
about tell me more about them my father
used to say that the lander layers were
little creatures that lived in closets
like elves no don't
he said that all they really were was
hair and teeth and fast little legs so
that they could catch up with all the
bad little boys no matter how quickly
they scampered stop it
you're scaring her yeah you're scaring
the little girl scaring the little girl
so everybody realizes that they can't
burn the fuel for the plane because fire
doesn't work in this world but you never
can make door care believes that you
might have the solution to our problem I
have the solution to our problem they
get to the plane and bring the food and
beer they used to have no flavor but it
turns out in the plane it does which
means time works okay inside and
therefore the fuel will work as well
however while everybody's looking at
that Balki escapes and gets himself a
knife but it's okay the little girl is
there to try and comfort him he's scared
to death I feel so sorry for him mr.
Toomy please come out
you know that's really scaring the
little girl scaring the little girl
don't you worry love we're gonna have to
be right as rain in no time flat
she's got internal bleeding we don't get
this blade out of her right now damn
quick she's not drowning around blood
what is right darlin right as rain she
is going to drown in her own blood right
is right darlin writers ray trout so
dorky and the black guy go looking for a
stretcher the bounty is there waiting
for him it's okay he's a black guy in
the Stephen King film they always turn
out fine right you want them too aren't
you a Langille ear
you know what figures this guy survived
three Silence of the Lambs movies and
yet it's a Stephen King flake that
finally kills him off tell me the man
the black guy always dies first turn but
the dork knocks him out with a toaster
in the bag and the Brit decides whether
or not he should kill him but then he
remembers how the blind girl told him to
leave him alive so that's exactly what
he does he doesn't tie up his hands or
anything he just sort of lets the
psychotic killer sit there until he
wakes up
what secret idiot service did this guy
work for again but get this the girl
even though she's been stabbed uses her
psychic powers to make Balki believe
she's really there Harry Craig now Stan
creep
just as the gift fuel to the plane and
everyone gets on board the girl creates
a false image again with her psychic
powers and meets Balki believe that he's
at the meeting he was trying to reach
you know is she so good at this yet how
come she didn't predict what she was
gonna get stabbed so he makes it to the
meeting and Fife s demon king is there
to give his blessing to this shitstorm
of a miniseries tell us how much money
you mean for us
I didn't make any money for you I didn't
make any money for you I lost money for
you actually I think this is how the
meeting went with Tom Holland and
Stephen King after this movie was
released but that correctly noise is
getting loud and we finally figure out
what's been getting closer and closer
all this time
yeah this is what we've been building to
all this time people some of the worst
CGI you'll ever see in your entire life
what are you screaming after just
overcooked meatballs
God these are making the spider from it
look real that's how bad it is people
come on just add in the other pac-man
characters and the goofiness week
by the way there's a black guy inside in
case you want to eat him too so as they
watch the film literally crumble before
their eyes the mystery writer decides he
needs one more monologue to sum up the
scenes we know what happens to today
when it becomes just waits for them the
timekeepers of eternity always following
behind cleaning up the mess in the most
efficient way possible by eating it well
yeah I guess you can't argue there it
really is the most efficient way
possible
sending giant elephant turrets with
chainsaw teeth to eat up every half
second of time boy God must have been
really fucking bad when they came up
with that idea all the time passes you
will see giant
sorry could you repeat that write it
down so as time is eaten up by killer
skeeball some point tries to retrace its
tracks and make it back to the time rip
what does a most secret classification
mean when you're just seeing a bunch of
killer cannonballs rolling up the world
look see but you put it like that it
sounds incredibly fucking stupid we see
that Dinah finally dies on the plane I
guess I stabbed in the lungs takes
longer than stabbed in the back to take
effect and they finally reach what
they've been looking for
ladies gentlemen
we have found what we were looking for
it appears to be a sky china okay here's
my question where the pilots who were
originally flying this plane taking a
look at that thing and saying yeah we
want to go through that seriously why
would they aim for this thing when they
consider the safety of the passengers
first hey Frank look at that isn't that
a score joy yeah that's a sky John it's
LOC together but the mystery writer
points out that they were all asleep
when they went through it the first time
and so they all had to be asleep to get
through it again so they decided to put
the pressure up to knock everybody out
but there's still another problem one of
us will have to stay awake to turn the
pressure up just before we fly through
the river so one of us one of us don't
have to die nobody not it not it
actually the British guy decides to
sacrifice his life I guess he's knocked
off so many other people it only seems
fair so everybody gets knocked out he
flies the plane through the rip
we both we like we're all counting on
you
and of course he ultimately disappears
why the hell his clothes shoes and belt
don't stay behind is anybody's guess but
who cares that made it home but is it
really home but what do you see out the
window no except for the obvious moving
cars down there oops they leaned the
plane and everything seems deserted but
that's because they realized that time
is catching up with you hear what you
said and the only way new people can
celebrate is by doing a stereotypical
freeze-frame
oh god this is stupid let me to its
credit it does keep you interested
enough to want to know what's going on
as most even King stories did some of
the actors are pretty good too but
there's just so many goofy performances
nonsensical logic bad effects and just
the stupidest letdown climax that's hard
to fully take it seriously I mean are
you really telling me that giant mutant
mud balls are eating all of the past
let's find out he doing here
I'm sending you 45 minutes in the pasta
city of your various kind well do we
have to yes all right
all right keep your beard on
everything seems to be okay
a shit yeah I thought we were supposed
to eat 2:30 we're supposed to eat 2:30
well maybe we're supposed to be 2:35
I'm pretty sure it was 2:30 um never
mind us we're just giant floating malted
milk balls here we're uh nothing out of
the ordinary at all everyday occurrence
aaaah no man this guy giant is gonna be
pissed
blaming you
scaring the little girl lady
hey you guys that since you've been so
nice and waited after the credits that
we have a special little thing for you
the that guy with the glasses vol.2 DVP
is coming out and it has all sorts of
good stuff it has a new ass that guy a
new poem review of Scott Pilgrim vs. the
world I knew how to be a pirate and to
accountable to nostalgia critics to new
ones
yes that's right it has a review of a
video game by a by Ekta get it nor does
they want video game and it also has a
review of reefer man as a classical film
it's wonderful wonderful but why am I
telling you this I'm telling you this
because you stayed after the credits
your gut fears but you can pre-order it
now that's right pre-orders start March
16th and we'll ship them out March 27
that's right you can to see them before
anyone else know when the DVD actually
does come out we'll have a commercial
we'll let you know but this is for the
people that actually no way to tell me
and credits love you so much oh whoa
boys oh my god Daenerys you can get it